Welcome to the Control Rig Mechanical Rigging Unreal Engine Training course.
The aim of this course is to go over a handful of useful functions and features available within Control Rig
that would help you in creating a rig for a skeletal mesh that needs mechanical accuracy.
We'll first take a look at some considerations you might need to make before getting into the engine
to help you plan out your Control Rig.
Now this will be about things like bone orientations and hierarchies depending on how something might need to move
and some thoughts about how you should be skinning your meshes.
Then we'll take a look at some specific functions and control types and settings that can be useful when you're creating a mechanical rig
to help you set up your controls in such a way that you can achieve more mechanical accuracy.
And then we'll jump into the engine to take a look at some of these tools in action,
building a control rig for one of the skeletal meshes within the project.
And lastly just to wrap up with some additional features that are available within the Control Rig Graph
that might be useful when you're building your own Control Rig.
We've included a project with the course content folder, so be sure to open that up and follow along as we're taking a look at these features
and building out the Control Rig.